مستمرون معكم في تغطيتنا المباشره
لتداعيات فجاعه الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
الكارثه التي دخلت يومها الثامن خلقت اكثر
من 37 الف قتيل في البلدين حتى الان في
تركيا تجاوز عدد القتلى واحدا
31,600 شخص اما في سوريا فقد تجاوزت حصيله
الضحايا
5300 شخص بحسب المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان في حصيله تتوقع الامم المتحده ان
تتضاعف مع اكتمال عمليات رفع الانقاض ياتي
ذلك في وقت تتفاقم فيه الازمه الانسانيه
في الشمال السوري مع التعثر وصول
المساعدات الاغاثيه للمنكوبين انا ميسون
عزام احييكم هذه الخامسه
[موسيقى]
رغم ان عمليات الانقاذ كانت غير ممكنه بعد
فتره اثنتين وسبعين ساعه التي تعتبر حاسمه
طبعا بعد كارثه الزلزال الا ان عمال
الاغاثه تمكنوا من انتشال المزيد من
الناجين تحت الانقاض بعد سبعه ايام
الله
جنبك تمام
وقد وصفت لجنه التحقيق الدوليه المستقله
بشان سوريا وصفت الاستجابه لطلب ارسال
المساعدات الى شمال غرب البلاد بالبطيئه
وبشكل وصفته بالمميت اكدت اللجنه الامميه
انه يجب التغلب على كافه العقبات
البيروقراطيه او السياسيه او القانونيه
لانقاذ الارواح واضافت ان هناك حاجه ماسه
لضخ مزيد من المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا
عبر كل الطرق الممكنه
على كل من جنديرس ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد
الاشقر اهلا بك محمد انقل لنا المشهد من
عندك تفضل
نعم يعني في الحقيقه مدينه جنديرس كما
يعلم الجميع تصدرت المشهد هنا في مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا نتيجه انها نالت النصيب
الاكبر من الدمار واعداد الضحايا الى حد
هذه اللحظه لا توجد احصائيه نهائيه لاعداد
الضحايا في هذه المدينه مع وجود فرص
لانتشال المزيد من الضحايا من تحت الانقاض
بدات الفرق الدفاع المدني بمرحله فتح
الطرقات داخل احياء المدينه ربما الساعات
القادمه او الايام القادمه ستبدا بها
ستبدا بها فرق الدفاع المدني مرحله يعني
ازاله الركام من المدينه ويليها مرحله
تدمير المباني المتصدعه التي تشكل خطرا
على المدنيين هنا طبعا اما بالنسبه للوضع
الانساني في هذه المدينه يعني المدينه
منكوبه بكل ما تعنيها الكلمه
جميع اهالي المدينه او النسبه الاكبر منهم
والتي تخطت عتبه التسعين بالمئه من
القاطنين في هذه المدينه هم ناجون متضررون
نتيجه هذا الزلزال اغلبهم لجا الى مراكز
الايواء المؤقته
ومنهم من لجا الى اقاربه في المدن والقرى
الاقل ضررا من هنا ومنهم لا يزال يفترش
الطرقات طبعا نحن في هذا المخيم وسط مدينه
جنديرس الذي الذي يقام هنا وينشا من خلال
يعني احدى المنظمات الشريكه لمركز الملك
سلمان من خلال المساعدات المقدمه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه طبعا دخلت احد
عشر حافله عن طريق معبر حمام وواصل
اغلبيتها الى مدينه جنديرس تم انشاء ثلاثه
نقاط تحتوي على مخيمات وستبدا الاستجابه
في مدينه ادلب من قبل هذه الحمله يوم غد
طبعا
في هذه المنطقه حيث نتواجد هنا قبل ما
يقارب الثلاث نعم نعم
هذه القافله تحتوي على على الفي خيمه سيتم
توزيعها ونصبها في اماكن متعدده في اكثر
من نقطه لتستوعب العدد الاكبر من
المتضررين سيتم تجهيز هذه الخيام
بمستلزماتها من اسفنج واغطيه ومعدات
وتجهيزات للمطابخ وغيرها طبعا كمرحله اولى
سيتم تزويد الخيام ايضا بصيله الاغاثيه
كانت محمله في هذه القافله ايضا وسلا
النظافه وغيرها من المساعدات الانسانيه
طبعا هذه المساعدات وصلت الى هنا لكن يعني
مع مطالبات ومناشدات باستمرار وصول هذه
مثل هذه المساعدات نتيجه العدد
من المتضررين الناجين من هذا الزلزال
وحاجتهم الماسه الى مثل هذه
المساعدات طبعا ان سمحت لي ان انتقل قليلا
للحديث عن الوضع الطبي هنا في المنطقه
طبعا نتيجه اعداد الاصابات المرتفعه جدا
المشاف جميع المشافي سواء كانت الخاصه او
العامه او المختصه باختصاصات متعدده جميع
المشافي يعني تمتلئ بالمصابين
الاطباء يعني عملوا منذ بدايه هذه الكارثه
منذ ساعات انطلاقتها الاولى يعني حتى هناك
متطوعون مرض ممرضون يعني لديهم خبره في
التمريض ذهبوا وعملوا في هذه المشافي يعني
لسد النقص في هذه النقطه طبعا المساعدات
الطبيه التي دخلت الى المنطقه ربما ست
ستسد حاجه المنطقه للعيادات المتنقله طبعا
هذه القافله بحسب مسؤول
التنسيق الطبي او مسؤول الاستجابه الطبيه
الدكتور براء قال لنا ان انهم سيسيرون
عشرين عياده متنقله ستتنقل بين مراكز
الايواء وبين مناطق انتشار الناجين
المتضررين من هذا الزلزال طبعا هذه
العيادات ربما ستخفف نوعا ما من حجم
معاناه يعني الاهالي وحاجتهم الماسه
للموضوع الطبي خصوصا اننا يعني نتحدث عن
ضحايا خرجوا من تحت الانقاض ونتحدث عن
امراض ربما ستصيب كبار السن والاطفال
نتيجه الحراره المنخفضه التي يعني نعم نعم
عدا الكوليرا عدا الامراض امراض السكر
وغيرها من الامراض التي تصيب الانسان عند
عند حالات الخوف والتوتر يعني
معينه نقاط تجمع لهم ام ماذا
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هناك العديد من
الاهالي لا يزالون يبحثون عن اقاربهم سواء
كان في المشافي او النقاط الطبيه
الميدانيه او حتى في مراكز الايواء يعني
ومنهم من يذهب الى المنازل المدمر التي
يقطنون فيها ويخبرون الدفاع المدني عن
امكانيه وجود
ذويهم تحت الانقاض ليباشر الدفاع المدني
بمحاوله البحث عن هؤلاء وانتشالهم يعني
السؤال الاكبر الذي يصلنا من السوريين
خارج سوريا اريد ان اطمئن على اهلي في
المنطقه الفلانيه باعتبار عملنا الصحفي
وعلاقات
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا التواصل مع محمد
الاشقر الصحفي من جنديرس على كل النكتفي
بهذه المعلومات ربما نعود اليه في سياق
هذه النشره والنشرات اللاحقه على كل
طالبت مديره صندوق النقد الدولي
كريستالينا
طالبت المجتمع الدولي بتقديم المساعده
لسوريا اثر الزلزال الذي ضربها وصرحت خلال
القمه العالميه للحكومات ان البلد الذي
يعاني اصلا تضرر بشكل كبير بعد الزلزال
وانه بحاجه مساعده فوريه وارسال الاغاثه
للمنكوبين داعيه للمجتمع الدولي للتصرف
ككيان واحد اضافت ايضا انه لا يمكن للناس
الانتظار ايام عده لوصول المساعدات وذلك
ردا على سؤال حول ضروره تخفيف العقوبات
المفروضه على البلاد والتي تمنع ايصال
المساعدات
على كل مزيد معنا من مدينه الكنديه
المستشار الاقتصادي الدكتور اسامه القاضي
اهلا بك دكتور اسمح لي ان ابدا بقراءه عن
بعد اذا صح التعبير للوضع في سوريا
والضربه الاقتصاديه التي لحقت بها في ظل
هذا الزلزال بتركيا تم رصد ما يمكن رصده
حتى الان ولكن بسوريا هل يمكن ان نقيم
الوضع هل يمكن تحديد الخسائر ام ماذا
والحقيقه تحديد يعني حجم الكارثه
الاقتصاديه بالنسبه للزلازل يعتمد على
عاملين اساسيين حسب الدراسات يعني قوه
الزلزال هل هو اكثر من 5.5 ريختر ام اقل
وعدد السكان المتضررين في المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال يعني اذا كان 5.5 مثلا او
اقل فتقريبا
الخسائر يقدرها يعني
الاقتصاديون ب 12 مليار دولار اما اذا
كانت اكثر من 5.5 الى سته فاصله خمسه يصل
الرقم الى 24 مليار دولار نحن نتحدث عن
كارثه يعني ربما
يعني قوه الزلزال الحالي تتجاوز 87 يعني
على مقياس ريختر هي الحقيقه اشبه ما يكون
بما تعرضت له اليابان بالزمان عام 2011
تكلفتها في ذلك الحين 231 مليار دولار لكن
البشر المتضررين كان يفوق 100 مليون
بكاليفورنيا بال 94 تعرضت ايضا يعني زلزال
سته سبعه كان حجم الاضرار حوالي 64 مليار
دولار
نيوزيلندا حوالي 16 مليار دولار لكن ايضا
قوه الزلزال سته فاصله واحد هذا كان عام
2011 في فبراري فالحقيقه عاملين اساسيين
هذا يعني يجب التركيز عليهم بالنسبه
لسوريا الوضع اولا لا يوجد سياده على
الارض السوريه
يعني احصائيات حقيقيه ثانيا المناطق
المنكوبه هي نفس التي تعرضت الى قصف
وصواريخ وبراميل وخاصه في حلب المناطق
الشرقيه التي تهدمت على مدى 10 سنوات
بمعنى اخر بس عندي سؤال بهذا الاطار انه
ما حدث
جراء الزلزال يضاهي الحرب والقصف الذي
تتحدث عنه ام ماذا
اه طبعا طبعا يعني هو على المناطق
المتضرره هو تقريبا بنفس الحجم لكن قصف
الروسي والنظام السوري عليها كان كان افزع
بكثير يعني كان في شهر واحد بالزمان هجروا
200 الف شخص خليني ارجعلك على هاي النقطه
اسمحلي لكن علي ان انتقل الى معبر ام جلود
شمال سوريا معنى من هناك مراسل العربيه
جمعه عكاش خبرنا ما الذي يحدث هناك جمعه
مرحبا ميسون انا متواجد حاليا في معبر ام
الدادات وليس معبر جلود بعد ان غادرت
المعضل لان هناك يعني قافله كانت مكونه من
66 شاحنه اخر اخر شاحنه دخلت الى الطرف
الاخر واتجهت الى الطرف الاخر منذ اقل من
دقيقتين يعني نحن نتحدث عن 66 شاحنه مقدمه
من اهالي شمال شرق سوريا منذ من رقه من
الحسكه دخلت باتجاه مناطق المعارضه ميسون
هذه هي القافله الثانيه التي تدخل اليوم
من المعبرين من ام جلود وايضا من عون
الدادات
جمعه قبل ما تنقل النقطه عندما نقول اخر
حافله لهذا اليوم لم يعد هناك ما يمكن
ادخاله ام ماذا
هناك ميسون يعني عدد من الشاحنات الاخرى
المتوقفه في ساحه التجمع هنا لربما يصارن
الى ادخالها يوم غد لكن القافله الكبيره
من 66 شاحنه اخر شاحنه اتجهت منذ حوالي
ثلاث دقائق من هذا المكان باتجاه نقطه
الصفر ليصار الى ادخالها الى مناطق
المعارضه طبعا هذه هي القافله الثانيه
اليوم واحده دخلت من ام الجلود شاحنه
واحده لاطباء بلا حدود 32 شاحنه
من اهالي منبج وريفها عشرين شاحنه اخرى من
مناطق متفرقه بمعنى 53 شاحنه دخلت من معبر
ام جلود 66 شاحنه من معبر عون الدادات
طبعا المعبرين يفصلان مدينه منبج من جهه
الاداره الذاتيه عن مدينه جرابلس من جهه
المعارضه وضح ايضا نقطه المساعدات المقدمه
من الاداره الذاتيه لا تزال عالقه في معبر
ام جنود وهي 30 شاحنه تحمل الوقود السبب
بذلك
لم لم يتم حتى الان يعني حل الخلافات بين
الطرفين في ظل غياب اي وساطه من القوى
الفاعله على الارض او حتى من يعني هيئات
الامم المتحده وهو جمعه اليس كذلك مع
الامم المتحده مع جرافيت حول هذه النقطه
تحديدا حتى الان لم تصل يعني الامم
المتحده الى تزويد جبل الخلافات بين
الفرقاء على طرفي
المعابر وبالتالي هذه المساعدات لا تزال
عالقه في طرف الاداره الذاتيه لربما يعني
تحدث يعني لقاءات او مفاوضات طيب
طبيعه طبيعه ما دخل حتى الان شو هي
المساعدات الموجوده يعني
الشاحنات اكثر من 100 شاحنه دخلت من
المعبرين معظم هذه المساعدات اغاثيه يعني
نتحدث عن خيام واغطيه وملابس شتويه وايضا
يعني انس غذائيه نتحدث عن
السلات الغذائيه والسلات النظافه اضافه
الى يعني اغذيه الاطفال وحليب الاطفال
لكن
شفافيه توزيع هذه المساعدات الى اي حد هي
واضحه والاليه تسير بانتظام اذا مصحه
تعبير
يعني بالتاكيد هناك مخاوف من المانحين
سواء كانوا او منظمات باليه توزيع هذه
المساعدات حتى انني كنت اسمع بعض سائق في
الشاحنات يقولون بانهم سيذهبون للاتجاه
الاخر ويشوفون على على التوزيع لان لا
توجد جهات رسميه او يعني هيئات او منظمات
اغاثيه تدخل مع هذه القاء القافلات تسلم
الى الطرف الاخر وعلى ترما يتم التوزيع
هنا اما من قبل المجالس المحليه او يعني
منظمات انسانيه او الدفاع
الدفاع المدني لكن الاليات التوزيع الغير
واضحه بالنسبه لنا على الطرف الاخر
منبر لكن لسنا بان الاليات ستكون على نفس
هذه الطريقه داخل المناطق المنسوبه
والاغلب هنا يقولون ستتوجه الى يعني بلدات
المنكوبه بشكل كبير مثل جنديرس وسرمدا
نتارب وحارم وفيما يتعلق كوننا نتحدث عن
المعابر هل هناك من عمليه نزوح تنقل من
جهه الى اخرى هل هناك من يراه
المتضررون بانه مكان امن بالنسبه لهم
يعني ميسون من مناطق المعارضه والنظام الى
مناطق الاداره الذاتيه التي اقف فيها لم
نشهد الدخول يعني نازحين او متضررين
يبدو ان المعابر يعني لا تعمل بشكل جيد في
هذا الاتجاه حتى عندما نتواصل مع المعابر
الواصله مع تركيا باب السلامه والراعي
والحمام ايضا لا يوجد تحرك من السوريين
المطاضرين شمال غرب البلاد باتجاه تركيا
حتى المصابين والجرحى معظم باب الهواء
اليوم اعلم بانها سيفتحون الطريق من تركيا
الى سوريا خاصه السوريين الذين يملكون
جمله الولايات العشره المتضرره ثم عادوا
يعني تصحيح البيان قال ايضا سيسمحون
للسوريين في شمال غرب البلاد من اعتبار من
يوم غد ذهاب الى الولايات العشره طبعا
الذين يحملون اوراق بانهم يعني يسمح لهم
بالذهاب الى هذه المناطق حركه التجاره عاد
الى معبر باب الهواء لكن في الاخرى يعني
تبدو خفيفه لان التركيز يكون على الاغلب
على المساعدات واستقبال الجثث يعني من
المعابر الرئيسيه مع تركيا تم استقبال
اكثر من 1300 تجسا لسوريين وصلوا الى هذه
المعابر وقتلوا في زلزال في المدن العشره
المكتوبه داخل تركيا كان معنا من معبر عون
اعدادات شمال سوريا مراسل العربيه جمعه
عكاش شكرا جزيلا لك
ومشاهدينا ننقل لكم هذه الصور الحصريه
للعربيه والتي تظهر انقاذ طفل يبلغ من
العمر 13 عاما بعد ان قد
اثنتين 1882 ساعه تحت الانقاذ وهذه الصور
اذا يتم تداولها عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي والقنوات التركيه ربما وهي
بهاتاي التركيه اذن انقاذ طفل يبلغ من
العمر 13 عاما بعد
282 ساعه تحت فيها طايق التركيه
12 عام وليست 13 طفل على كل الاحوال تم
انقاذه في ما يوصف طبيا بانها معجزه خاصه
بانه الوقت الذي كان بالعاده ما يؤمل فيه
بالبحث وانتشال ضع احياء قد انتهى ولكن لا
زلنا حتى هذه اللحظه تتصاعد الامال بانقاذ
المزيد في ظل ازدياد اعداد من تم انقاذهم
حتى الان شرحنا في بدايه هذه النشره حول
عدد من الاشخاص الذين تم انقاذهم من اطفال
ايضا من نساء ومسنين تم انقاذهم بالساعات
الاخيره وهذا يعطي بارقه امل على امكانيه
انقاذ المزيد من الاحياء من هم تحت
الانقاض
هذه عوده مشاهدينا مره اخرى الى ضيفه من
اتوا الكنديه المستشار الاقتصادي الدكتور
اسامه القاضي شكرا جزيلا لانتظارك نعتذر
ولكن كان من المهم العوده الى مراسلنا
لمعرفه التطورات كنا نتحدث عن اذا مصحه
تعبير مقارنه ما بين
الاضرار التي سببتها الحرب الاهليه وما
بين ما سببه هذا الزلزال وان كان يمكن
المقارنه بين الاثنين
فهو الحقيقه يعني المقارنه مع الفارق
[موسيقى]
الخراب الذي يعني يخلفه ثلاث اربع براميل
ديناميت فوق رؤوس الاهالي تعادل 5000
قتيله اللي ماتوا بهذا الزلزال رحمهم الله
شهداء بالمناسبه بمناسبه انقاذ هذا الطفل
توجهت البارحه بنداء ويدني كثير من
السوريين الى اهل الى اصدقائنا في الخوازل
البيضاء ان يستمروا يعني كمان 48 ساعه في
يعني ولا يتوقفوا عن يعني
البحثال الجثث ووقف عمليات الانقاذ لانه
حتى الاليات غير متوفره ولكن نتمنى
السلامه للجميع ونتمنى ان نستمع الى
الاخبار الطيبه دكتور دعنا نركز على
الجانب الاقتصادي لانه كما ذكرنا بالبدايه
تركيا قادره على حصر وتقييم الاضرار ولكن
هناك صعوبه
في سوريا نحو ذلك وبالتالي هذا ينعكس على
اعاده الاعمار اليس كذلك بالضبط بالنسبه
للمناطق اللي في سوريا اعاده اعماره
تقريبا صعب يعني ربما يعطوا بيوت مسبقه
الصنع ربما يبنوا بناء بسيط لكن ان تاتي
ببناء يقاوم الزلازل ربما تستطيع ذلك لكن
اي دوله ستتحمل تكاليف هذا البناء ضمن عدم
وجود حل سياسي حقيقي لا سمح الله اي قصف
اخر جديد يزيل المبنى من جديد بالنسبه
لتركيا الوضع مختلف وضع امن اكثر طبعا
بناء يجب ان يكون الان بمواصفات عاليه جدا
الاستفاده من التجربه اليابانيه في بناء
المباني هو عدم التساهل فيه عن طريق
البلديات من حيث اسامه هذا يحتاج الى
تكلفه عاليه اي من الدول قادره الان في ظل
وهنا ربما يمكن التركيز على تركيا في ظل
الضربه القاسمه اقتصادها الذي تعرضت له
وبالمقابل عندما نتحدث عن اقتصاد مقابل
الانتاج او الدخل بالنسبه للدول وميزانيه
الدول والعجز التجاري ماذا عن سوريا
لا بالنسبه لسوريا يعني تقريبا اعاده بناء
كل هذا يعني شبه مستحيل
اللي بده يصير هو بناء جزئي او ابني مسبقه
الصنع او مخيمات لايواء كل هذا الكم
الهائل من العوائل التي تضررت بالنسبه
لتركيا دخل بالاصل يعني ديونه اللي تجاوزت
400 مليار دولار هي كانت مشكله
عفوا العمله مضروبه ايضا
هو كله كله يؤثر على سواء العجز التجاري
وسواء التضخم ثم اتى طبعا الديون الهائله
اللي موجوده مع ارتفاع اسعار الفائده او
تخفيض سعر الفائده وهذا ادى الى مزيد من
التضخم مساهمه به ايضا كل هذه المشاكل اتت
الان مشكله جديده من اين له ان يتحصل على
كميه يعني يعني انا بقدر يمكن لا يقل عن
الان بتركيا ضمن الدراسات على الاقل 20 او
30 مليار دولار يعني
سوريا
وعندما عندك عقوبات على سوريا بالمقابل
هذا بالنسبه لتركيا بالنسبه لسوريا اصلا
يعني
[موسيقى]
المناطق التي هي يعني تحت سيطره النظام هي
بالاصل مهمله لانه لا في كهرباء ولا في
ماء ولا في ومعاشات متدنيه جدا ولا يوجد
اصلا بالموازنه ما
يفي حاجه حتى دفع الرواتب يعني
موازنه السوريه كان المفروض يكون في عليها
عجز يبدا بسبتمبر اعتقد العجز بدا من
الشهر الرابع
انخفاض العمله لاكثر من سبعه الاف باعتراف
البنك المركزي البرنامج الاغذيه العالمي
وصف الحاله
بطريقه تعكس الواقع الزلزال ضرب واحده من
اكثر المناطق هشاشه في العالم وهنا نتحدث
عن الجانب الاقتصادي ينطبق على كل شيء
والانسان وغيره سيدتي نحن كنا كنا عام على
مؤشر الفيلد ستيت اندكس على مؤشر
الدول الهشه كنا تقريبا اكثر دوله هشه
اكثر اربعين دوله هشه في العالم هذا 2011
قبل الثوره الان هي تقريبا ثاني اكثر دوله
هشه وفاشله في العالم انا اعتقد يعني الان
يعني اما اعلان انتداب رسمي على هذه
الدوله او وصايه حقيقيه عوده الى عصبه
الامم وترك الامم المتحده جريفث نفسه صرح
البارحه على انه في فشل ذريع باداء الامم
المتحده وانه الناس معهم حق يشعروا انهم
متروكين لمصائرون تواضع الامم المتحده في
الاغاثه مش فالحه في السياسه كيف حتفلح
يعني فلذلك يجب انقاذ يعني حتى الشعب
السوري الموجود تحت منطقه النظام السوري
تبع يعني تبع جوع وفقر والان جائز زلزال
من الذي سيغيث هؤلاء وحتى
الكنديه المستشاره الاقت الدكتور اسامه
القاضي شكرا جزيلا لك
خسائر متزايده في الارواح والاملاك
والاقتصاد سببه الزلزال المدمر الذي اصاب
سوريا الاسبوع الماضي ليضيف معاناه اضافيه
لاقتصاد انهكته صراعات سياسيه
لاكثر من 12 عاما وما زالت مستمره غياب
البيانات الرسميه والشفافيه واتساع رقعات
تاثير الزلزال بين مناطق خاضعه للنظام
واخرى للمعارضه يزيدان من صعوبه تقدير حجم
الاضرار والتي تجاوزت بالمجمل عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات
وحول الخسائر الماديه افادت منظمه الخوه
البيضاء بان اكثر من 300 وخمسه وسبعين
مبنى انهار كليا واكثر من 1200 مبنى انهار
جزئيا كما تصدعت الاف المباني الاخرى كما
اصاب زلزال اقتصاد سوريا في مقتل خاصه انه
ضرب اربعه محافظات مسؤوله عن اكثر من ثلث
اقتصاد البلاد
فمحافظه حلب المتاثره الاكبر من الزلزال
مسؤوله عن اكثر من 16% من اقتصاد سوريا
فيما تمثل محافظه حماه المرتبه الخامسه
بنسبه مساهمه في الاقتصاد السوري بما يصل
الى تسعه في المئه ثم اللاذقيه في المرتبه
السادسه بسبعه فاصل ثمانيه في المئه
مساهمه بالاقتصاد اما محافظه ادلب التي
تنقسم السيطره فيها بين النظام والمعارضه
والمتاثره بالزلزال تصل مساهمتها في
الاقتصاد الى 2.7%
انقسام الوضع السياسي في سوريا يزيد من
معاناه المتاثرين بالزلزال المدمر اعاده
الاعمار على الجانب السوري خاصه في
المناطق التي تخضع للمعارضه والتي في
الاصل تضم مئات الالاف من المهجرين ستكون
الاصعب في غياب رقابه حكوميه وهرب من
المسؤوليه من المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
شادي الزعيم العربيه
قال مسؤول بوزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان
العقوبات الاوروبيه المفروضه على سوريا لا
تنطبق على المساعدات الانسانيه او الالات
الثقيله المستخدمه في انقاذ ضحايا الزلزال
وانتشالهم من تحت الانقاد اشار مدير دائره
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا في الخارجيه
الالمانيه طوبياس تنقل الى ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي ساعد السوريين على مدار الاثنتي
عشره سنه الماضيه بارسال مساعدات قيمتها
11 مليار يورو مؤكدا ان العقوبات لا تحضر
اي مواد غافيه تدعو اليها لحاجه في سوريا
قال المبوث الاممي الى سوريا جير بيدرسون
انه استمع الى تطمينات من الحكومه السوريه
بشان العمل في جميع انحاء سوريا لتقديم
الدعم والمساعدات للسوريين المتضررين من
الزلزال في جميع انحاء سوريا مضيفا عقب
لقائه بوزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد
بان التركيز سينصب على الدعم من خلال
المعابر الحدوديه
ستبذل الامم المتحده كلما في وسعها لدعم
الشعب السوري في هذه الازمه كما اكدنا على
ضروره العمل في جميع مناطق سوريا وساعدت
بسماع التطمينات من الحكومه السوريه بانها
ستدعمنا في العمل الذي نقوم به في جميع
انحاء البلاد لانه كما نعلم جميعا كان
هناك تحد خاص فور وقوع الزلزال للحصول على
الدعم في شمال غرب سوريا
وفي جندرز السوريه لم يتوقع الطفل محمد
يجد نفسه بين ليله وضحاها بدون اهل او
ماوى وبعد كارثه الزلزال حيث فقد عائلته
بين ركام المنزل فقد والدا والديه
وشقيقاته وتبقى له من اسرته زوجه عم
والدته ياسمين مرجان من نقرخان التركيه
والالم وخيبه الامل تبدو واضحه على ملامح
الطفل محمد عقيد الذي فقد كل عائلته في
جنديرس السوريه محمد لم يكن يتوقع ان
تنقلب حياته بين ليله وضحاها ليصبح يتيما
بعد ان كان الطفل المدلل في وسط عائلته
ليجد نفسه اليوم بدون ماوى بعد الزلزال
الذي حول منزله الى حطام راح بين ركامه
والداه وشقيقاته وتبقى له من اسرته زوجه
عمي والدته ياسمين مرجان من قلخانه
التركيه
انا تركيا انا واطفالي انهدم بنا المنزل
في جنديرس وليس لدينا اي مكان للبقاء فيه
ليس لدينا منزل اريد الخروج من المستشفى
لكن للاسف ليس لدينا مكان ياوينا اريد ان
تتم مساعده هذا الطفل
محمد بعد ان كان وحيدا لاهله اصبح وحيدا
لزوجه عمي والدته التركيه الاصل وهما
الناجيان الوحيدان من كل الاسره جراء
الزلزال المدمر في ناحيه جنديرس السوريه
لم يتبقى لنا شيء لا اريد الخروج من
المستشفى حتى تتحسن صحه ابني انا تركيا
وبسوريا ليس لدينا اشخاص نذهب عندهم اريد
ان يتم تقديم المساعدات لي
هول الصدمه لا يزال باديا عجز عن الكلام
والتعبير فالموقف لا تقوى تلك الملامح على
تحمله او حتى على الاقل تقبله
وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال المتحدث باسم
منظمه اليونيسف في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا محمد الحواري قال ان تداعيات
الزلزال جعلت سوريا في وضع ماساوي مشيرا
الى ان اكثر من مليون وسبعمئه الف طفل
سوري يعانون من حياه غير صالحه للعيش
لذلك تقييم الوضع انه ماساوي صعب جدا
يحتاج الكثير والكثير من التظافر والتعاون
حتى نصل الى مرحله شبه مرضيه لحال هؤلاء
الناس ولا يخفى عليكم بان المنطقه ككل هي
متدربه بسبب عدد مرات النزوح واللجوء فيها
وهناك نقص مستدام للمساعدات بل ان اكثر من
مليون و300 الى مليون و700 الف طفل في
المنطقه هم يعانون من شتى انواع الحياه
الغير صالحه للاستمرار سواء كان بسبب فقر
الدم او التقزم او الهزال وهناك اكثر من
500 الف امراه في نصف مليون امراه من
الحوامل هم من عندهم فقر دم اساسا قبل هذه
الحاله فما بالك اليوم
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من القاهره المتحدثه باسم
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي ريم ندى اهلا بك
سيده ريم يعني الاخبار التي تاتينا من طرف
برنامجكم
لتشيي بالخير اذا مصحه تعبير اخر
التصريحات تتحدث عن انه المساعدات بدات
تمتد عن ماذا نتحدث
عفوا الصوت يتقطع اذا بدك تعيدي السؤال لم
ابدا بالسؤال كانت النقطه الاساسيه انه في
تصريحات من برنامج الاغذيه العالمي تتحدث
ان المساعدات بدات تنفذ وبالتالي السؤال
الان هل انتم بانتظار المزيد من المساعدات
ام تنتظرون مناشده للحصول على مساعدات
وبالتالي ايصالها للمحتاجين
هو اهم ما طلب به برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
هو فتح كل منافذ الدخول خاصه الى سوريا
للوصول الى كل الاشخاص الذين يستطيع
البرنامج مساعدتهم برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه يعمل بسوريا لذلك كان من السهل
عليه في الساعات الاولى لحدوث هذه الكارثه
الوصول الى الاشخاص بعض الاشخاص المتضررين
في حلب وفي طرطوس وفي ادلب والقرى
المجاوره وايضا في اللاذقيه ولكن لان
المساعدات كانت مستمره على مدار الايام
الماضيه ولان برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
لديه مخزون من الغذاء
لمساعده برنامج الاغذيه العالميه يوفر
حصص الغذائيه الشهريه
للخمسه ونصف المليون شخص في داخل سوريا كل
شهر لذلك كان هناك مخزون من الاغذيه ولكن
الاغذيه التي تناسب هذا الظرف وهي الحصص
الغذائيه الطارئه التي لا لا تحتاج الى
الطهي لان لا يوجد اماكن للطهي لا يوجد
بيوت اصلا لكثير من هؤلاء الاشخاص هذا هو
ما يتعين على برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
ايصاله الى كل المناطق السوريه المتضرره
متوفر ريم ليس لديكم يعني الاعتماد الكلي
الان على ما هو من المخزونات السابقه هذا
ما تقولينه
طبيعي برنامج الاغذيه العالميه يقوم بنقل
الاغذيه من تركيا ومن الداخل السوري بصفه
مستمره نظرا لان هناك
اشخاص مستفيدين من البرنامج ولكن
الغذاء المناسب لهذه الحاله يجب اعاده ملء
المخازن كان هناك كميه مازال هناك بعض
الكميات من هذه الاغذيه الطارئه ولكن في
الايام القادمه البرنامج
قد ناشد ويزال يناشر فتح كل منافذ الدخول
الى شمال سوريا سواء المناطق التي تحت
سيطره النظام او شمال غربي السوريه
المناطق التي خارج السيطره يعني هل بحسب
ما نفهم انه المعابر في معظمها قد فتحت
الان لايصال المساعدات هل هناك من معرقلات
بالنسبه لكم انتم او لا
الان يعتمد تعتمد المنظمات الاغاثيه على
معبر واحد فقط من تركيا الى سوريا الى
شمال سوريا
وهو معبر باب الهوى كان قبل عامين هناك
معبرين اخرين مفتوحين امام المساعدات
الانسانيه
ولكن الان هو معبر واحد فقط وهناك ضغط
كبير عليه نظرا لحجم الاحتياجات
وضروره السرعه في ادخال هذه المساعدات
بمعنى اخر القوافل بما تريدونه متواجده
على المعابر ولكنها لم تدخل حتى الان في
تكدس هذا ما تقولينه ام ماذا
حتى الان برنامج الاغذيه العالميه يعتمد
على مخزونه في داخل سوريا ولكن في الايام
القادمه سيقوم البرنامج بنقل
المساعده في الغذائيه من تركيا ومن داخل
سوريا فتبقى الايام القادمه يعني نحن نامل
في ان تفتح كل المعابر طبعا سيظل البرنامج
يستخدم معبر باب الهوى ولكن نظرا للكميه
كميه الاغذيه التي يجب توافرها ايضا هناك
احتياج للاموال فبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي
اطلق نداء للمساعدات الطارئه في
للمتضررين من هذه الكارثه في تركيا وسوريا
وهذه يعني هذان هما المطلب المطلبان او
الاحتياجات الاساسيه
لمواصله عمليات الاغاثه لبرنامج الاغذيه
العلميه للمتضررين وايضا الاشخاص الذين
يعيشون في ظروف صعبه اصلا صحيح بس حتى تتم
الاستفاده او الاستماع والاستجابه لهذه
المناشده حجم ما لديكم حتى الان للتعاطي
مع الوضع الان عندك ارقام او لا
في اي منطقه تتحدثين ادخاله لسوريا لانه
مناشدتكم هي فتح باء باقي المعابر وايضا
قضيه الاموال ولكن قلت انه في مساعدات
موجوده حجمها
المساعدات كانت حوالي تكسي المساعدات
الطارئه كانت تكفيلم 125 الف شخص في شمال
غرب سوريا الان تم توزيع
في شمال غربي سوريا مساعدات غذائيه ل 50
الف شخص وتم توزيع مساعدات غذائيه في حلب
من الوجبات الساخنه والمساعدات الطارئه في
طرطوس واللاذقيه وحمى
حلب لحوالي
تحضرك الارقام يمكن على كل
مش مشكله على كل نتمنى فتح المعابر كما
ناشدتم والحصول على باقي المساعدات من
القاهره المتحدثه باسم برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي ريم ندى شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات
اعلن ياسر ترافي منسق للاستجابه الطارئه
بالجمعيه الدوليه لرعايه الكوارث والذي
يعمل في مخيم الاغاثه السعودي في جنديرس
بشمال غرب سوريا اعلن بدا عمليه توزيع
المساعدات السعوديه التي وصلت من مركز
الملك سلمان للغاثه في جندرس تعاون نتابع
طبعا بدايه بحب اذكر انه اول شيء الطائره
دخلت من خلال معبر جوي اغاثه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبين تركيا طبعا هذه
الطائرات دخل منها الى سوريا قافله واحده
اللي هي عباره عن 11 شحني بقيه الحملات
حيث يتم توزيعها بين سوريا وبتركيا
بالنسبه للجانب السوري فاللي دخل هو عباره
عن 11 شاحنه من خلال معبر الحمام الحلول
مع تركيا هاي الشواحين تتضمن عده مواد
اللي هي مواد غذائيه خلال غذائيه ومواد
غير غ طبعا كانت عباره عن خيم وسلال ايواء
واغطيه
للناس اللي ضررت ياثر الزلزال اللي صار
الجنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا طبعا هاي
الموادعها بمناطق ادلب ومناطق عفرين احنا
حاليا متواجدين به وسط ناحيه جنديرس عم
نقوم ببناء واحد المخيمات طبعا هذا المخيم
رقم ثلاثه اللي احنا عم نباشر فيه ان شاء
الله وغدا الفرق راح تكون متواجده بمناطق
ادلب لا ان شاء الله رب العالمين حنحاول
نوصل لاكبر عدد ممكن من الناس اللي ضررت
خلال الفتره القادمه
ساطلب من زميلي المصور ان ان يعني ان يدخل
قليلا الى
الخيام ولكن التجهيزات هنا تخوننا دائما
التجهيزات الانترنت صعوبه التواصل تخوننا
دائما في الدخول بين الاهالي ولكن في
النشرات القادمه سندخل بين الاهالي
سنستضيفهم طبعا كما تلاحظون على شاشه
الكاميرا هناك العديد من العوائل التي اتت
الى هنا تنتظر الانتهاء من بناء هذه
الخيام لكي يستلموها لكي يؤمنوا انفسهم
بعد ايام عصيبه مرت عليهم في ظل موجات
البرد الشديده التي تضرب المنطقه ليل
الامس يعني صراحه كانت درجه الحراره هنا
ناقص درجتان اغلب هؤلاء الاهالي كانوا
يبيتون في مراكز الايواء المؤقته منهم من
كان يبيت امام منزله المدمر بشكل جزئي
يخاف دخوله نتيجه يعني
وجود هزات ارتداديه تحدث بين الحين والاخر
اكد اطباء مستشفى التدريب والابحاث بمدينه
اضنه التركيه ان الطفل الضاحك الذي تم
انتشاله بعد خمسه ايام قضاها تحت الانقاض
في انطاكيا اكدوا انه بصحه جيده وسيبقى
تحت رعايتهم الى ان يتم الوصول الى والديه
[موسيقى]
من هاتاي جنوب تركيا ينضم الينا موفد
العربيه عمار الهندي اهلا بك عمار انقل
لنا المشهد من عندك
على ميسون
ميسون الحديث يعني يدور هنا عن المساعدات
الانسانيه والنازحين الذين هجروا من
بيوتهم بسبب الزلزال طبعا كنا رصدنا في
هذا المركز لاواء السوريين اعداد كبيره
وقصص محزنه ولكن انتقلنا بطبيعه الحال الى
هذا المخيم الذي يتم انشاؤه الان ليستقبل
النازحين من المدن
والاحياء عفوا من الاحياء المدمره في
انطاكيا وفي هاتاي عموما هذا
مخيم من المفترض ان يتسع الى سته الاف
لاجئ ناجح تقريبا تجهز لهم جميع
الاحتياجات اللازمه اسمحي لي سريعا ميسون
ان اتحدث الى احد المسؤولين في هذا المخيم
وسيساعدني الزميل طارق في الترجمه ولكن
لمعرفه تفاصيل اكثر عما يحدث هنا ومتى
يجهز ومتى واليه كيف يعني سياتي السكان
الى هذا
طارق من فضلك لو تساله اولا كم سيتسع هذا
المخيم كم سياخذ من العدد
الذي سيتسعه تقريبا كبدايه 4000 شخص قابل
للزياده كل خيمه تتسع لعشر اشخاص يوجد
الان 164 خيمه جاهزه حاليا
يعني الناس تسجل للمجيء الى هذا المخيم ام
عشوائيا
[موسيقى]
جمعيه الاحباب الخيريه بالتعاون مع منظمه
افاد اداره الكوارث التركيه يتم التنسيق
بينهم لاستقبال العائلات والعائله
والعائلات تقدم طلباتها للمجيء الى هنا
والسكن لكن كل هذه الامور تجري تحت
تحت اشراف منظمه افاد اداره الكوارث
التركيه
ممكن تساله انه هل هذا المخيم حكر على
الاتراك ولا يستقبل الجميع من مختلف
الجنسيات مثلا سوريين وغيرهم
بهاركي اسمها
منظمه افاد ونستقبل الجميع دون اي تفرقه
لا لجنسيه ولا لاي عرق يعني نستقبل الجميع
طيب هذه الخيام ستكون مدفاه ستكون مزوده
بكل حاجيات الناس اللي احتاجونها مثلا اذا
ما عندهم ملابس اذا جاؤوا بملابسهم اللي
خرجوا فيها من منازلهم المدمره هل سيوفر
لهم كل شيء
هزمات نادر بدون
الشوادر او كما يقولون الخيم معزوله فيها
نظام عزل سوف تعزل يعني لا تستقبل البروده
ولا تخرج الحراره والتدفئه سوف تكون حراره
عن طريق الكهرباء سوف نقدم هذه الخدمه
لجميع القادمين هنا
يقول انه المكان مش سيجهز بكامل
المستلزمات للجميع يعني عذر لسوء الوقت
نشكره على وقته نعم ميسون كانت هذا هذه
مقابله سريعه مع هذا المسؤول عن هذا
المخيم الذي يجهز بالكامل حسب ما يقول
لجميع الجنسيات لن يكون هنالك تمييز في
استقبال الناس وسيكون مدفئ وسيحوي تقريبا
4000 شخص كمرحله
الى اكثر من ذلك والعائله
صحيح شكرا منها تاي جنوب تركيا موفد
العربي عمار الهندي شكرا جزيلا لك ولضيفك
طبعا سنواصل هذه التغطيه للزلزال لكن
نتوقف مع بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات اخرى
نقلت مجله بوليتيكو الامريكيه عن مسؤولين
في الاتحاد الاوروبي القول ان الاتحاد يعد
لفرض حظر تجاري على صادراته من السلع الى
روسيا واكدت المجله على ان القيود
الاوروبيه تشمل ايضا فرض حظر اضافي على
صادرات المكونات الالكترونيه التي يمكن ان
تستخدمها روسيا في صنع الاسلحه
وزيره خارجيه المجارية بيتر سيارته
العاصمه البيلاروسيه منسك اليوم بهدفي
ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه واكد ان خلال
محادثاته في بيلاروسيا سعيه لتحقيق السلام
في اوكرانيا بحسب تعبيره
قال الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسي ينس
ثلث في حاجه الى توخي الحذر واليقظه عقبور
بالونات صينيه الى داخل الاجواء الجويه
الامريكيه والكنديه مضيفا ان هذه الوقائع
تعكس نمطا تتبناه الصين وروسيا لزياده
المراقبه وياتي ذلك بعدما اتهمت الولايات
المتحده اتهمت الصين بادخال بالون طائر
للتجسس لاجوائها وقامت باسقاته فيما نفت
بكين الاتهامات الامريكيه
تظاهر عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين خارج
البرلمان ضد تعديل للنظام القضائي المثير
للجدل والذي يهدف الى تعزيز سيطره اعضاء
البرلمان على المحكمه العليا التعديلات
المقترحه للنظام القضائي من شانها ان تتيح
للبرلمان الاسرائيلي الغاء اي قرار
للمحكمه العليا بغالبيه بسيطه من 61 نائبا
في المجلس المكون من 120 مقعدا كما ان من
شانها احكام قبضه السياسيين على النظام
القضائي واليه تعيين القضاه
التغطيه مستمره مع الزميله راويه مشاهدينا